Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
during the last legislature this
Parliament decided on over 700 different
the facts which affect the future of
each and every one of us in the European
Union many important areas of decision
will also be passed on to the next
European Parliament for example the
ratification of the agreement on brexit
the European Union's
budgetary framework for the next seven
years
the recolor policy reform and so on but
the outcome of these elections will also
play a very important role in deciding
who will be in charge of the next
European Commission and remember no
candidate can become president of the
Commission without the support of the
absolute majority of the European
Parliament that is 376 members we should
therefore not forget the importance of
what happens here tonight the European
Parliament is the democratic heart of
Europe it represents the citizens voice
in the EO and elections are the full
embodiment of this role so far citizens
in seven countries have cast their vote
with 21 21 and more countries voting
today preliminary data shows that
compared to five years ago turnout in
the majority of these countries
including some of the bigger is going up
the last poll stations will close at 11
p.m. tonight and we will provide you
with all the updated information in the
lead up to that I will now give the
floor to Marjorie who will provide you
with an overview of all the technical
facilities and services are you disposal
here tonight Marjorie thank you John and
hello everyone I will guide you
throughout the evening through updates
of the projections as they come in
but first some household information
especially what you can expect in
technicals for tonight from us in the
European Parliament in Brussels
first of all interpretation for the
evening will be provided in six
languages these are English French
German Spanish Italian and polish our
present spokesperson services will be
present through the night for any
current inquiries you may have if you
don't see them immediately please ask
for them at the main desk in front of
the chamber the hemicycle other
questions you may have you can also ask
them press officers covering all the
different in your countries are based in
a newsroom in the Yehudi Menuhin space
two floors down from here you can
identify them by the flag cards they
will have pinned on there at your
disposal to answer any questions you may
have including if you want to know more
about the information that Philippe is
about to give you press officer from the
political groups in the European
Parliament are also here in the chamber
to help you for instance if you want
background information a political
reaction organise an interview etc
finally a reminder that the Parliament
will remote may remain open 24/7
throughout Sunday and Monday and this is
it for me for now Germa provide us with
a more detailed overview how this
evening will all route in terms of
provision of estimate and then resolves
please sure thank you Rama
very good afternoon to everyone of you
before disappearing down in my
data-crunching cave for the rest of the
night let me briefly tell you what
you're going to see both on the big
screen here and also on our dedicated
results website election - results top
you you have the link here on the screen
as from 6 o'clock tonight and throughout
the night basically our main data center
is located just below your feet one
floor down a secondary facility we have
in Brussels and teams in all 28 member
states are standing by to face
election data into our system we're a
team of roughly $140 specialists and
analyzed analysts ready we will bring
you and the citizens around Europe
projections and results for the member
states and the overall Parliament in
near-real-time
you have all received this part of your
documentation for tonight a tentative
timing schedule if not our colleagues of
DG come have this document ready for you
in the always latest version please do
understand that these are all timings
that are necessarily indicative our work
depends on the availability and on the
robustness of the data that we are
receiving from the Member States be it
exit polls estimations or later on
results so for the concrete timing
tonight at around 1815 so there is
already a small delay of about 10
minutes our contractor cantar will
provide national estimates for the first
seven countries Austria Cyprus Germany
Greece Ireland Malta and the Netherlands
we will update with further exit polls
at 7:00 and at 8:00 by five more
countries which brings us then to 8:15
2050 in Brussels time when we are
planning to release a first EP
aggregation based on the exit polls and
estimates from these twelve member
states and pre-electoral voting
intention survey data for 16 member
states
so this first aggregation and that's
important is not based on any election
result yet and therefore due to the
available information at that point in
time it will also further evolve
throughout the evening with an update
expected for Aston line and after 10
o'clock this evening after the close of
all polling stations in the U at 11
o'clock tonight member states will then
start publishing their official results
of the European elections and we can
plan to release our first result
projection for the European elections
2019 based on official results from 22
members
dates at 11:15 tonight updates will then
come in at the hour and we expect to
publish the last update for this night
around 2:30 in the morning which will
allow us to have more or less a robust
picture from the UK no further updates
are then planned for the rest of the
night giving you a small risk in the
night we expect releasing further
updates than in the morning around 10:00
a.m. now for the issue of turnout as
jean has already indicated the first
reports from the member states have been
quite encouraging nevertheless the
publication of an average you turn out
will depend again on the availability of
data from all 28 member state and at
this point in time we cannot yet
announce a fixed date when we can
publish such a average turnout it's
likely that we might be able to have a
first turnout estimate before 11 o'clock
and more robust projection figures on
the turnout after 11 o'clock now let me
briefly take you through what you will
be seeing on the screen here as from
6:10 we are distinguishing roughly four
scenarios national estimates this is
country specific data based on exit
polls or estimations provided before the
official results are coming in after 11
o clock we will switch to national
results projection based on the official
results as they are released by the
national election authorities for the
European level all the other published
before 11:00 o'clock this is what we
then called the EP aggregates will be
labeled as estimate and said before
based on exit polls and pre-electoral
voting intentions after 11 o'clock
European level data will be labeled as
provisional results and be based on an
increasing degree of official results
coming from the member states now if we
are looking here at this
what you can see is the country
estimates both for before 11 o'clock and
after 11 o'clock no need to take
pictures it says clearly it's test
starter this is not actual data yet you
will see per country the projections in
percentages for the different national
parties if there are more parties we
will show this on two screens a second
view will give you the seeds that we
project for this country for the
different political groups so let's see
if next to the next one there will also
be the turnout data that we can provide
as soon as we have a robust projection
for these countries now if we're looking
at the results overall for the European
Parliament it will be a breakdown for
the different political groups the
overall view the number of seats the
difference to the outgoing Parliament
and then we might have as a next slide
the classical view of the hemicycle as
you know it for this place it is also
important to understand that tonight
Parliament will provide the result
painted on the canvas of the outgoing
Parliament which means we're taking the
groups as they have been in the last
plenary session of this year the
question of the formation of political
groups as you know is up to them and
their newly elected members and as there
are a number of national parties
standing a realistic chance to obtain
one or more seats in these elections and
these parties are either not yet
represented in the European Parliament
or they are not member of any European
political party we are projecting them
in an artificial category which is
called others distributed visually 50%
each on the left and on the right end of
the hemicycle spectrum parties are shown
throughout the evening in this category
others
an official announcement has been made
that they would join a political group
only then we would change them so in
this sense I'm happy to announce a few
changes that we already had the GUI and
jail group has requested that any seats
for the Belgium party ptb should be
attributed to them the green group has
likewise requested the seats for the
Portuguese party PA n pan should be
represented under their banner and last
but not least the older group has
officially crested that for the results
presentation tonight seats for the
Romanian party us are plus as well as
for the French list Renaissance grouping
into others candidates from La
Repubblica Maj shall be attributed to
them Alda has equally requested that the
group's name shall as a working title be
presented as elder plus Renaissance plus
USR plus lots of pluses thank you very
much thank you very much Philippe
just one more piece of information by
now you will also have the opportunity
to listen to firsthand reactions from
leading politicians later tonight
tonight and ask your questions this will
happen at two key moments first leaders
of political groups of this Parliament
will come on stage after 8:30 p.m. for
statements followed by a few questions
and second the candidates for the
presidency of the European Commission
will be here at around 11:30 p.m.
danke voila a tous new suet Oh excellent
[Music]
[Music]